I know it welcome students when you're
playing mossing and somehow I think you
place the Dutch I have some vague
recollection I don't know okay doesn't
play the Dutch a video is on and
sometimes you just don't see it is on or
not so what do we get mr. Muslim we not
start with this probably a bit more
aggressive yeah greedy he wants the pawn
[Music]
we all want porn sir I just gives me the
porn back okay yet Suzanne position time
that I had on the board quite a lot and
I think that white can be quite happy
it's an easy to play and why it just has
a small advantage White has an extra
Center porn him who play on the
queenside and black him count even
develop all that easily I mean I don't
really see where the pieces should go
and Bishop 128 in particular you kind of
quickly come to the conclusion that you
probably have to trade it we should
reform and take and yeah that's not
particularly great if you have to do
that so I'm just putting more pressure
there yeah if b6 it has to be played
then
[Music]
I'm definitely liking my position okay
it's a surprising choice
[Music]
94 then what will create
please stop the drilling but there is
really little that I hate more on than
those those drilling noises and kind of
wrong and this is like the worst okay
where to put it maybe just can so I
think I have some time here to improve
III 24 is hard to prevent basically
impossible to prevent yeah no I think
I'll go for it don't have to it it just
it should net me the pair of bishops as
six can cannot run away cannot run away
the bishop only six mmm what what is
this is to go to e7 on what is the deal
ok I'm taking this and now that couple
of things can still play 4 p-5 or just
be happy with my way of the ships
[Music]
as far as possibly 95f 45 is something
that in general I would like to do well
95 I can also just take this heaven so
that doesn't work I think it isn't
drilling actually I think they they are
cutting whoa they're cutting the lawn in
front of my my place yeah white is in
desperate black is in desperation moved
here already so mote mote not moot so f
for Hanks i think i can take it I just
take the same on Queen takes I go Quincy
form that position is a disaster or
queen bee three
actually an ef5 is hanging let's just
trade queens the resulting resulting
position is just just fantastic for wife
I just heck the night on 125 to make
sure that I'm keeping if I'd fall so I
am just taking yeah caption
[Music]
night he wants to go night-night f 896
this is IDM okay let's prevent that for
the moment last night e 7 now as a
threat and night deform
[Music]
look six maybe an idea here
[Music]
this is doing the job
[Music]
takes it behind upon people should end
it
[Music]
time morning maybe hookah a six was
working somehow yeah oh oh my goodness
yeah yeah I fell into some some
kindergarten trap great great
great the only way to not win this game
which was totally one-sided from from
the very beginning
I don't know he plays in such a strange
way and vegetable cable to do something
yet there are answered yeah I should we
should take this draw of course it said
was a little bit I couldn't really take
it it just timewise I was just moving
let's say I can always get to this pawn
game drawn I what an idiotic drawn and
only way to do not windows what was to
fall for this trick down yeah again I
think the whole the whole opening is not
good I hear you for was even stronger I
because Bishop f4 get it would have one
already it cannot go here I am Bishop f4
is complete disaster and I am brilliant
then it was ok I mean that Coach is just
good good good got just got just slowly
outplay and then I always forgot i can
take b7 i can just take me seven the
whole time that's strange but this is
also fantastic you've got the payout
bishops better center all blacks pieces
are barely placed and so on so I mean
okay hmm my ears tricks there are only
five so i should have flight
one of the other things something yeah
you have this this 95 business here I
currently the pieces are a little bit
off never do but what what did i do he
am so yes this is this how can I screw
it up this actually isn't take it clear
unbelievably I have to play what you
want just can't check here jack yeah
that should still win quite clearly may
I know I cannot move this piece I mean
that was terrible I just enjoy it yeah I
should just lose but it wasn't exactly
good technically speaking rookie six now
yeah yeah I'm okay now Jack I could have
done I mean I could have just taken be
seven why didn't I do that I mean this
is nice yeah everything's okay yeah but
I just take be seven it's a big porn and
it's the end of black structure may I
was to relax them else to relax them ok
guys thanks for watching